das leben wird immer teurer und teurer
und energie für viele unbezahlbar
die politik weiß dass sie eingreifen
muss damit aus einer energiekrise keine
soziale krise wird aber wem sie helfen
und wie ziemlich vielen und bloß nicht
noch mal so wie bei der gasanlage möchte
man rufen da droht die spd chefin saskia
esken heute abend gar dem
wirtschaftsminister mit einer blockade
im deutschen bundestag wenn er an diesem
gesetz nicht noch mal schraubt wir
müssen reden mit diesen gästen
christian lindner bundesfinanzminister
und fdp chef
niedersachsens ministerpräsident stephan
weil spd
ramona barth von der
verbraucherschutzzentrale thüringen
die wirtschaftsweise veronika grimm
und robin alexander journalist bei der
welt sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner
und
die begrüßte zu der sendung
ausgesprochen herzlich sie haben das
verfolgt liebe zuschauer die preise
kennen nur eine richtung nämlich nach
oben die politik sucht noch eine
richtung
die gasanlage eine bomben idee die zum
rohrkrepierer mutiert dramatisch die
erteilung des wirtschaftsministers
die alternative ist nicht keine umlage
die alternative wäre der zusammenbruch
des deutschen energiemarktes und weil
die umlage belastet musste schnell eine
entlastung her die mehrwertsteuer auf
gasverbrauch zeitlich befristet auf 7
prozent abzusenken
eigentlich ging es nur um die rettung
von zwei unternehmen das hätte der staat
auch direkt leisten können da fragt man
sich mit dieser bürokratische aufwand
wirklich notwendig oder die
trittbrettfahrer die jetzt von der
umlage profitieren könnten die
rechtsverordnung zur gas anlage die auf
dem tisch liegt erfüllt nicht das was
robert habeck in der vergangenen woche
versprochen hat jetzt kommt raus es
bewerben sich auch unternehmen die fette
gewinne einfahren und dividenden
ausschütten das geht nicht
das geht nicht und saskia esken sagt
heute abend dass sie im deutschen
bundestag das angriffsrecht geltend
machen würde wenn robert habeck diese
gas um lage nicht verändert und
verhindert dass die falschen davon
profitieren das ist gleich eine
wunderbare einstiegsfrage an den
ministerpräsidenten niedersachsens
ist das ding eigentlich schon tot
entschuldigung wenn ich das so frage
aber grundsätzlich glaube ich erst mal
das deutsche gesetz das heißt peter
struck auch ein niedersächsischer
sozialdemokrat kein gesetz verlässt den
bundestag so wie es rein gegangen ist
aber so erklärt man mal besser intern da
wird es wahrscheinlich wirklich
veränderungen gehen und herren es ist ja
das deutsche parlament ja nie sowas
klärt man innerhalb einer koalition
besser intern versteh vorher das macht
den besseren eindruck und in dem fall
wird sicherlich so sein dass es viele
themen gibt das ist ja völlig neues
instrumente stellen sich viele fragen
und wenn die bahn zu beantworten sind
und ist es gut und ansonsten muss man
was ändern wie ist der ihre haltung dazu
würden sie sagen als bürger verstehen
sie was die regierung tut das ist eine
umlage mit der eigentlich insolvente
unternehmen gerettet werden sollen
mehrwertsteuer wurde gesenkt eigentlich
sind aber auch drei umlagen die erhöht
wenn haben sie das verstanden finden sie
das ist ein guter vorschlag das ist
tatsächlich so dass die kritik glaube
ich berechtigt dass die begründung mit
der der bundeswirtschaftsminister am
anfang die umlage begründet hat
eigentlich nach und nach immer mit mehr
fragezeichen versehen worden ist und
dann durch die mehrwertsteuersenkung man
sich schon fragen kann braucht die dann
eigentlich noch oder braucht es sie in
diesem umfang aber dazu kann vielleicht
herr linder etwas sagen mit einer worten
ich glaube dass da eine intensive
diskussion im bundestag schon notwendig
ist und die wird ja jetzt wohl folgen
aber bevorzugter weise vielleicht intern
und zwar deswegen weil viele bürgerinnen
und bürger bei diesen meldungen hin und
her und rauf und runter inzwischen den
durchblick verlieren und das ist nicht
gut man könnte sagen es ist eine
zumutung haben ein externer ist bei uns
journalisten kollege von der welt ist
das eine erste veritable krise dieser
ampel die linke hat sich zu wort
gemeldet und gesagt dass er die
unsozialste maßnahme einer regierung
seit der agenda 2010 jetzt kommt also
nun auch noch heraus dass milliarden bei
konzernen landen könnten die
wenn man es nicht verändert die die gar
nicht brauchen ist
dieses gesetz schon tot und warum wird
dieser kampf öffentlich ausgefochten
interessant ist doch wie fing das an
also hat diesen vorschlag gemacht dann
sagt der herr lindner ich rufe mal in
brüssel an ob wir darauf vielleicht
keine steuern zahlen lassen können
brüssel athen überraschend gesagt nein
auch ihr müsst euch an die gesetze
halten darauf fallen steuern an dann
sagte der bundeskanzler wiederum völlig
überraschend dann machen wir die steuern
für den gesamten gas runter was er auch
schon nicht zusammenpasst und herr
habeck hat erst gesagt die anderen
unternehmen wollen das gar nicht jetzt
sagt frau s die wollen das tor und wir
müssen ein habig impala wenn zwingen
dass er erst noch ändert und herbig ist
gerade im münsterländischen unterwegs
bei einem unternehmertag da haben wir
von der welt ein reporter und der sagt
habeck hat gerade auf der bühne gesagt
ihm hätte es war ganz viele juristen
gesagt man könnte das nicht so machen
dass es gerecht ist also dass die leute
die es nicht brauchen es sich trotzdem
und aber er will es jetzt doch noch
einmal versuchen ich weiß jetzt nicht ob
ich sagen würde große krise aber das
beste regierungshandeln ist das dann
vielleicht doch nicht oder wie sind bei
christian lindner bundesfinanzminister
herr lindner selbst kollegen aus ihrer
partei sagen dass man das nicht versteht
milliarden von von den verbrauchern zu
nehmen um konzernen zu helfen die es
eigentlich gar nicht brauchen
machen sie sich in reim drauf ist eine
sehr offene frage verstehen sie
die absicht bei dieser gas umlage ist ja
eine völlig andere es geht nicht darum
irgendwelche konzerne zu retten sondern
es geht darum
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher zu
schützen der hintergrund ist dass manche
kundinnen und kunden bei einem
gasversorger gekauft haben oder einen
vertrag abgeschlossen haben und der muss
nun ausfallen dass russisches gas
ersetzen und diese speziellen
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher hätten
und plötzlich exorbitant höhere
gaskosten und ein anderes wird sondern
ein anderer versorger er hat kein
russisches gas muss nicht ersatz
beschaffen und dort steigen bei den
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher die
preise nicht so stark und die idee des
wirtschaftsministers war und sie ist im
kern richtig er beteilige ich mich nicht
an der pauschalkritik dass man sagt wir
machen eine
solidarische lösung unter den galgen
kunden und gaskunden jetzt kommt das was
herr alexander gesagt hat ins spiel auf
eine an eine geste der solidarität unter
den menschen noch mehrwertsteuer zu
erheben das also der staat von
solidarität profitiert das wäre völlig
falsch und unethisch gewesen nun haben
wir das was uns möglich ist gibt es eine
europäische rechtliche möglichkeit das
was uns als bundesregierung möglich ist
vorgeschlagen nämlich dann auf die
gesamte gaslieferung die mehrwertsteuer
zu reduzieren und damit kompensieren wir
als nächstes in europäisches recht gibt
dass der gegner steht das ist richtig
aber dennoch kann man einer solchen
ausnahmesituationen ja fragen sieht die
europäische kommission unsere not kann
man eine ausnahme machen also ich hätte
mir vorgeworfen nicht gefragt zu haben
aber ich mache mir keinen vorwurf
geprüft zu haben aber das geht nun
schauen wir jetzt schauen wir sind jetzt
schauen wir wie ist die wirkung und kann
ich das bestätigen was alexander sagt
was angeblich der kollege habe gesagt
hat aber richtig ist jedenfalls eine
maßnahme der solidarität kann nicht dazu
dienen dass einzelne unternehmen ihre
rendite pflegen und gewinne darauf
machen und das muss man sich genau
ansehen um was es da geht ich kenne die
fakten da nicht das kennt er habe viel
besser aber wenn es eine notwendigkeit
gibt etwas zu verändern um dieses
instrument zielgenauer zum einen
verbraucher profitieren dann schauen wir
uns nicht vor korrektur gut wir sind
natürlich als nächstes bei der frage ob
es alternativen zu dieser gas umlage
gegeben hat und die liegen jetzt ja noch
offener in der landschaft uns ist
zugeschaltet aus frankreich aus
perpignan heute abend veronika grimm
eine der wirtschaftsweisen mitglied des
sachverständigenrates frau grimm die
einen sprechen von murks die anderen von
einem schildbürgerstreich in bezug auf
diese gas umlage wie würden sie sagen
ist die
ein versehen ja im prinzip war das erst
mal im prinzip war das erst mal eine
gute idee zu sagen diese differenzen in
den kosten des entfallen ja liefermengen
die aus russland gekommen sind und
müssen ersatz beschafft werden zu einem
viel höheren preis und dadurch die
entstehen eben zusätzliche kosten und
die hat man jetzt nicht auf die kunden
überwälzt die davon betroffen werden
oder die vielleicht gar nicht mehr
beliefert worden wären wenn man das halt
hätte einfach laufen lassen sondern man
hat die verteilt mit der gasanlage und
prinzipiell ist das erst mal eine gute
idee weil dann steigt ja der preis
das gibt einen sparanreiz wir haben ja
parallel das problem dass wir extrem
viel gas sparen müssen um für den winter
gewappnet zu sein falls denn tatsächlich
ein gewisser weise sind gaal auch so
schon otto fischer und hätte man sagen
wenn ja
dann hätte man sagen können na ja man
entlastet im gegenzug die gasverbraucher
und zahlt denen eine
kompensationszahlung so dass sie eben
nicht so stark unter den hohen preisen
leiden da gibt es verschiedene
vorschläge zb einen gewissen grund
verbrauch zu einem sehr geringen preis
anzubieten und da die post die
preisdifferenz zu den aktuell hohen
preisen zu erstatten über die versorger
da gibt es verschiedene modelle und das
wäre der richtige weg gewesen dann wäre
nämlich der gaskonsum prinzipiell also
viel gas zu verbrauchen wäre dann teuer
und das ist wichtig weil wir eben
wirklich gas sparen müssen um für im
internet zu sein indem es möglicherweise
nicht so viel gas zur verfügung die die
fliegen also gleichzeitig hätte man eben
dann die kunden entlasten können so dass
eben diese zusätzlichen kosten nicht in
dem maße zu buche schlagen daher der
richtige weg dass man durch die
mehrwertsteuersenkung den preis im
gegenzug senkt ist eigentlich
kontraproduktiv
das ist ihre these ich will nur noch mal
sagen diesen einem bestimmten verbrauch
der verbraucher zu stützen das ist ein
vorschlag den interessanterweise die cdu
die linken und auch die gewerkschaften
gemacht haben einen gewissen decke leben
mit eben sechs oder sieben cent nur
bezahlen zu lassen und darüber dann die
menschen andere preise zahlen zu lassen
ich will es nur zu ende erklären damit
unsere zuschauer uns auch verstehen ich
verstehe sie richtig dass sie sagen sie
halten diese gas umlage grundsätzlich
für richtig sie hätten eben nur für eine
andere entschädigung plädiert richtig
genau genommen hätte eben so
entschädigen sollen dass der preis an
reiz also der anreiz zu sparen
angesichts der vom kreis erhalten bleibt
aber gleichzeitig diese extreme
belastungen der konsumenten der
verbraucher eben nicht stattfindet so
und dennoch haben wir ja den hässlichen
tatbestand dass wir nun offensichtlich
eben auch unternehmen auf der
gewinnerseite stützen die gar nicht in
einer not sind also in einer
wirtschaftlichen insolvenzsituation
unbedingt vorstellen wollen wir unseren
fünften gast heute nämlich am 100 ballot
sie ist energie expertin von der
verbraucherschutzzentrale in thüringen
frau wo sie haben natürlich nicht aus
der zeitung aus dem fernsehen erfahren
müssen in welcher situation die bürger
dieses landes sind die rufen ständig bei
ihnen an sind das jetzt erst mal noch
verständnisfragen der menschen
mehrwertsteuer runter umlage eigentlich
sind drei anlagen und sie bitten um
aufklärung oder sind das schon echte
beratungsgespräche in der not die sie
für also wir führen zurzeit alle
möglichen gespräche das sind einmal
konkrete beratungsgespräche weil es
natürlich die ganze menge
energieversorger gibt die die preise
mittlerweile schon mehrmals erhöht haben
in diesem jahr oft auch ungerechtfertigt
erhöht haben die auf wollen natürlich
rechtliche hilfe haben von uns wir haben
die verbraucher die sagen okay es kommt
eine erhöhung ich möchte jetzt
irgendetwas machen was kann ich
technisch irgendwie wo kann ich
einsparen und da haben wir die energie
einspar beratung schon seit vielen
jahren bieten wir an aber wir haben
zunehmend auch leute die da weiß man gar
nicht so richtig wollen die nur einfach
mal ihren frust loswerden wollen die uns
ankündigen dass er sich jetzt das leben
nimmt das haben wir tatsächlich an in
den gesprächen also unsere berater sind
noch heillos überfordert damit also das
wird auch immer mehr eine sozialberatung
die wir eigentlich gar nicht anbieten
können
sie haben gelesen zur kenntnis genommen
selber gespürt kriegen bestätigt dass
die regierung versucht hat zu reagieren
mit zwei entlastungspaket tank rabatt
wir sind beim neuen euro ticket im
september kommen 300 euro energie geld
auch steuerfreibeträge sind erhöht
worden dass alles daneben als erst zum
ende des jahres
schlägt das in irgendeiner form zu buche
also schon mal in der form dass die
leute wirklich völlig konfus sind da
muss ich kann weil zustimmen es ist also
das ist eine kommunikations management
und krisenkommunikation bei der
regierung lässt zu wünschen übrig und
die lässt auch das vertrauen ein
bisschen singen in das krisenmanagement
der regierung weil niemand mehr so
richtig durch sieht worüber reden wir
jetzt eigentlich gerade gas umlage
gasspeicher umlage welche regel energien
alle möglicher kram und dann ist es
natürlich auch so dass viele helfen
einfach mal so mit der gießkanne
ausgegossen werden also dieser tank
rabatt den namen auch höher verdienende
und haushalte sehr gerne mitgenommen
aber die hätten es eigentlich gar nicht
nötig gehabt das geld wäre nötiger
gewesen bei den haushalten die entweder
schon in hartz4 sind oder rentner
studenten die wohngeld empfänger sind
aber auch die haushalte mit niedrigerem
einkommen die bisher noch überhaupt
keine beihilfen bekommen die aber
wirklich gar nicht wissen wo sie das
tuch hinziehen sollen war ja nicht nur
die energiepreise stark gestiegen sind
eher nicht nur gas und dann auch
strompreis ist gestiegen es sind ja auch
lebensmittelpreise gestiegen leute die
kinder haben und jetzt schulsachen
kaufen müssen die wissen gar nicht woher
sind das leben sollen sie haben das
vorhin nur angedeutet glauben sie denn
dass es neben einer welle bedürftigen
auch eine klagewelle geben wird dass
menschen sich auch wehren werden auch
versuchen werden mit ihrer hilfe
juristisch zu wehren gegen diese sperren
die dann als nächstes energiesparen die
auch als nächstes kommt na ja zuerst mal
haben wir schon sehr viele versorger
abgemahnt weil sie ungerechtfertigte
oder falsche erhöhung schreiben
verschickt haben also haben wir jetzt
ganz viel in der pipeline schon es wird
ja die erhöhungen nicht oder liebe
packen wir die sind völlig unklar es
herrscht gerade völlig wird am besten im
energiemarkt also da werden preise
erhöhen also einmal steigen die preise
ins utopische und diese gas umlage das
sind eigentlich nur peanuts also mir hat
jetzt eine kollegin aus sachsen erzielt
da wurde der gaspreis mal eben von sechs
cent auf 30 cent erhöht also 30 cent das
ist ein sprung preis den man jetzt noch
zahlen ja das ist natürlich also da muss
man jemand hingucken das erwarten wir
tatsächlich vor den kartellämtern oder
wen auch immer da muss jemand hingucken
und sich einen überblick verschaffen und
nicht nur hingucken sondern auch und
dann natürlich auch kinder und dann
natürlich auch mal sagen so leute bis
hierhin und dann weiter geht es nicht
das fordern wir tatsächlich auch
jetzt muss ich überlegen wie die frage
eigentlich wollte dann nach der
klagewelle fragen eben weil die häuser
auch sperren ja also gegen die sperren
weiß ich nicht ob da eine klagewelle
kommt vorher muss müssen die klagen
einfach schon mal kommen gegen diese
erhöhungen aber auch also wir bereiten
gerade unser bundesverband bereitet zum
beispiel auch gerade zwei muster
feststellungsklagen vor gegen
energieversorgung fox energie und ich
glaube prima energie oder so die halt
besonders dreist am markt ag am markt
agieren also da man muss sich rechtlich
wehren man muss energie sparen keine
frage man muss ich gucken was kann ich
rechtlich rausholen und dann müssen wir
aber auch die beihilfen noch stimmen sie
haben auch ein paket an vorschlägen
sicherlich in ihrer westentasche würden
sie sagen das was die union und die
linke und der dgb vorschlagen ist
eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht apropos
fairness dass man eine grundlast an
verbrauch den menschen subventioniert
und sagt was drüber es bezahlt ihr zu
den markt gängigen preisen und wir
subventionieren einfach das was jeder
mensch braucht um zu überleben und einen
begrenzenden raum warm zu kriegen im
winter den grundgedanken finde ich
absolut plausibel interessanterweise
wird jetzt die österreichische
bundesregierung exakt zu diesem thema
auch eine expertenkommission eingesetzt
die gebeten wird innerhalb weniger
wochen dazu einen praxisgerechten
vorschlag zu machen es würde ich mich
ehrlich gesagt bei uns auch wünschen
dass wir es einmal durchkalkulieren es
kann auch sein dass man den kreis derer
denen dieses budget garantiert werden
kann dass man den eingrenzen muss würde
ich gar nicht ausschließen aber ich
finde das erst mal einen wirklich
interessanten gesichtspunkt der stammt
ursprünglich von sebastian dullien von
der bürgerstiftung und wer hat schon
eine menge in sich und dann sind wir bei
den inhaltlichen und bei den politischen
konsequenzen noch mal robin alexander
was wird es jetzt bedeuten wenn diese
diskussion um die gas und an umlage in
der ampel tatsächlich eskaliert und man
keine lösung finde ich würde gerne auf
eine wirkliche merkwürdigkeit hinweisen
christian lindner sagt solidarität
solidarität üben wir doch in unserer
gesellschaft wenn jemand schuldlos in
not geraten ist sind diese unternehmen
die schulden aus der not geraten es
handelt sich um zwei unternehmen das
eine heißt juniper das andere heißt
gazprom germania juniper hat wie kein
anderes dieser unternehmen auf
russisches gas gesetzt die haben auch
politischen lobbydruck dafür gemacht die
haben auch namensartikel veröffentlicht
dass diese gas punkt 2 pipeline gebaut
wird die haben also geholfen und putins
schlinge um den hals zu legen und
gazprom germania war nun putins schlinge
also das ist erstmal ist da auch ein
unternehmerisches fehlverhalten drin so
und jetzt werden diese unternehmen
gestützt das ist natürlich richtig weil
es nicht auf die stadtwerke und auch die
verbraucher gehen soll aber zb der chef
von juniper war jetzt mit robert habeck
und olaf scholz in kanada auf dieser
reise und erwirkte auf dem flug schon
sehr entspannt für jemanden der jeden
tag ein paar millionen euro verliert und
wollen jetzt überlegt man sagt
solidarität dann ist es doch eigentlich
so dann machen wir es alle warum denn
nur die gaskunden also ich zum beispiel
wohnt in berlin wenn sie in berlin in
der mietwohnung wohnen da gibt es welche
die glas da gibt es welche sind an der
fernwärme angeschlossen die leute wissen
gar nicht dass die in berlin war
einschulung und die leute haben sich
alle als die kinder weg waren
unterhalten wo bist du denn dran so also
das ist doch der kreis der leute die
solidarität üben sollen ist doch
eigentlich willkürlich gegriffen und das
sind alles fragen die man wirklich
streng gern beantworten haben wir jetzt
christian lender wir fangen an mit der
wichtigen frage an sie ob wir diese
gasanlage nur haben und nur diskutieren
weil der bundesfinanzminister christian
lindner nicht bereit war diesen beiden
unternehmen um die es eigentlich geht
aus dem haushalt zu helfen also sie zu
stützen wie wir in corona ganz viele
unternehmen gerettet haben oder sich der
staat sogar beteiligte frau immer das
tun wir mit vielen milliarden euro
verdient hatte dieser staat das
unternehmen juniper und mit vier
milliarden euro sind wir auch dazu
übergegangen zu intervenieren bei der
früheren gazprom germania in cannes ist
auch unrichtig was herr alexander sagt
diese unternehmen werden nicht gerettet
und ihren einfach am markt sondern der
staat ist reingegangen und der
hintergrund dann haben sie im nebensatz
alexander gesagt ist wir wollen
verhindern
ein effekt wie seinerzeit bei den lehman
brothers bei der damaligen finanzkrise
dass es einen
unvorhersehbaren effekt gibt wie beim
domino spiel wo die steine alle umfang
am ende ist das einzelne stadtwerk
betroffen wie robert habeck hat diese
gas umlage sage es nochmal nicht
konzipiert für die rettung irgendwelcher
unternehmen sondern die ist konzipiert
damit die verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher bei bricht und die die strom
also die die gasversorgung mal geworden
sagt in meinen worten nicht um den
zusammenbruch der gasversorgung es geht
darum stadtwerke zu schützen und das
nicht einsam bruch das in alternative
zur lage sorgen dass andere umlage ja
der zusammenbruch des energiemarkt ja
ich kenne das zitat aber ich will ja in
meinem garten stränden dem eine worte
sind wir schützen damit die
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher denn
also die die
ältere dame in thüringen die einen gas
versorgungsvertrag hat die hat noch
nicht entschieden ich bin russisches gas
sie haben gerade gesagt schuldlos in
diesen ältere frau ist schuldlos in not
wusste ich dass die russische star auf
die unternehmen betreiben aber wir
helfen menschen die sonst schuldlos in
not geraten sind mit dieser umlage jetzt
werden der schauen ob sie auch ihre
zwecke erfüllt ich weiß dass der kollege
habeck das genauso aufmerksam betrachtet
wie wir ja alle so wir sind in einer
krisenhaften situation etwas nicht
möglich ist dass der staat mit seinem
haushalt die gesamte gasversorgung mit
steuermitteln übernimmt das ist nicht
möglich sondern was wir tun können ist
beispielsweise eine solche umlage
organisieren einzelne unternehmen
stützen und dann vor allen dingen uns
kümmern um die besonders verletzbaren
haushalte also die menschen die mit
ihrem ihrem einkommen nicht mehr das
leben finanzen beim verbraucher hier ein
aber sie sammeln eben beim nur
gasverbraucher ein das versteht man
nicht da sahen wir in der letzten
sendung hier auch schon diskutiert aber
das gang ist eine solidarischen akt
braucht warum wir den dann nicht auch
für die öl- und für die menschen nehmen
die mit strom heizen auch geht also
wir haben in diesem jahr ja pakete
geschnürt die die ganze breite der
bevölkerung mit unterschiedlichen
maßnahmen erreicht haben das wird jetzt
ein drittes entlastungspaket für den
winter geben da werden da auch
über andere und auch bekannte maßnahmen
sprechen um ich gerade sagte also von
den rentnerinnen und rentnern den
menschen in der grundsicherung mit
geringem einkommen wie iris bis sie
nimmt ja dass in die arbeitende mitte
eine unterstützung zu leisten damit
niemand angst hat vor leeren kühlschrank
und kalte wohnung darum nur die gas
kommt auf der anderen seite machen die
organisatoren der solidarität innerhalb
der gaskunden auf der einen seite auf
der anderen seite über die allgemeinen
steuermitteln bezahlt auch der jemand
derjenige der eine ölheizung hat die
zahlen auch sie die solidarität über die
steuermittel und da sind in diesem jahr
30 milliarden euro gewesen von
einmalzahlungen für
grundsicherungsempfänger bis rückwirkend
ein stück nur nicht warum diese umlage
eben nur von den gaskunden die zahlen
liegen noch nicht was ihn noch mal
erklärt weil der eine gas kunde bekommt
sein gas aus norwegen der andere da muss
kein ersatz beschafft werden der andere
gaskunde bekommt sein sie wussten gar
nicht ob sie aus russland oder aus
norwegen gaskrieg so ist es und deshalb
hat
und deshalb hat robert gesagt wir machen
eine umlage weil der einst die einzelnen
gaskunden der andere gaskunde weiß nicht
wo er herausbekommen hat also sind alle
miteinander solidarisch das ist erstmal
ein und bemerkte zu juniper loswerden
das ist ja nicht gerettet worden das
unternehmen weil zu hübsches oder sowas
sondern weil es der zentrale deutsche
großhändler für gasimporte 60 prozent
der
stromimporte gegenüber juniper und das
letzte was wir hätten brauchen wer an
dieser stelle chaos gewesen dass wir in
dem die weitergereicht worden hunderte
von stadtwerken gehört werden dann auch
in turbulenzen geraten das war absolut
richtig dass wir den gedanken der
solidarität folgen dann aber auch dass
sie möglichst breit anlegen das wiederum
teil ich denn genauso wie natürlich die
gegen die norwegische gas bekommen sagen
könnten ja was geht mich an das ist ja
was ganz anderes könnte mit der gleichen
logik könnten dann auch die co2 das
sagen aber in wirklichkeit muss es darum
gehen eine sonderlast für eine gruppe so
oft möglichst viele schultern zu
verteilen und damit wieder mal so gut
ist meine liebe und dann ist auch robin
alexander daran alle menschen selbst der
kleinste stadtkämmerer steht jetzt vor
einer unglaublichen aufgabe der muss in
alle rechnungen seiner bürger diese
umlage mit hinein rechnen der muss eine
zweite und eine dritte umlage noch dazu
rechnet er muss die mehrwertsteuer
rausrechnen und es geht auch jedem
unternehmen so und zwar egal in welchem
bundesland um eine ganz banale frage ist
aufwand nutzen wenn sie sich derweil
diesen aufwand und den nutzen anschauen
denen dieses projekt politisch jetzt
bringen wird ist das gerechtfertigt ja
das ist eine finde ich sehr berechtigte
frage es wird immer komplizierter
und in der tat ist die frage ob man
tatsächlich nicht durch einen
entsprechenden wahrscheinlich massiven
eintritt des staates auf dieser
großhandelsebene die dinge wesentlich
erleichtern können aber da sind die
würfel jetzt gefallen und wir müssen
jetzt einfach auch weiterkommen wir sind
in dieser hinsicht ja sie haben gesagt
dass sie glauben dass wir das intern
geregelt werden soll sie glauben daran
dass es eine interne lösung gibt oder
können diese sich vorstellen dass er
eine erste ampel krise ist und warum
streng frau eske ennen das an ich bin
ziemlich sicher dass man sich einigen
wird denn diese fragen die hier
behandelt werden oder die umlage als
solche die ist ja koalitionsintern würde
ich mal statt an dem vor intensiv
miteinander besprochen worden und jetzt
geht es darum wie man es im einzelnen
macht da gibts noch beratungsbedarf das
ist ganz sicher so aber dass daran jetzt
nicht weiter reichende krisen noch
anschließen das sehe ich nicht es wäre
auch nicht verantwortbar ehrlich gesagt
wir haben eine solche situation einen
solchen problemdruck von einstellen dann
müssen wir nicht noch welche dazu
bringen wo ist eigentlich der
bundeskanzler frage ich mich wann würde
sich olaf scholz zu dieser frage melden
robin alexander das kann ich nicht
vorhersehen
meldet sich ja immer relativ spät aber
dass man sich einig eine ampel glaube
ich auch die frage ist nur worauf weil
das ist doch das problem warum kann ein
so eloquenter menschen christian lindner
das nicht hier erklären dass alle zu
hause sagen okay leuchtet eine gute
sache sagen sie jetzt einfach so
weil das ein kompromiss ist das hätte
robert habeck nie gemacht wenn er hätte
alleine entscheiden können daniel bahr
ist das ist der finanzminister von
so ein vordenker der grünen in diesen
dingen hat ziemlich offen gesagt nee so
das ist ein kompromiss zwischen grünen
und fdp wie viel spd dagegen denkt über
sehe ich nicht und der ist so geworden
wie es ja manchmal in der kur in der
politik geht dass man am ende sicher
etwas einigt was nicht so wirklich
funktional ist und das ist schon ein
problem und da müsste auch und muss ihre
frage zurückzukommen irgendwann olaf
scholz sagen das können wir jetzt nicht
zwischen saskia esken
das nicht was herr nicht allerdings an
da gerade gesagt hat ist einfach nur
ausgedacht es stimmt nicht dass das ein
kompromiss zwischen grünen und fdp wäre
sondern dass ein vorschlag der regierung
aus dem federführenden
wirtschaftsministerium das ist nicht
irgendwie hängen sie haben das von der
regierung dagegen wurde vorher nicht
gesprochen selbstverständlich haben wir
in der regierung mit entschieden aber
sie stellen es so dar als hätte es einen
völlig anderen vorschlag aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium das grün geführt
ist gegeben und die fdp habe dagegen
irgendwie gesagt nein geworden etwas an
wenn man sie sagen das ist hart becker
und der freundliche mann darüber
gesprochen das hätte er auch gemacht
wenn er nicht mit ihnen koaliert hätte
davon gehe ich aus
da bin ich ja mal gespannt was die
grünen haben sie dann andere
informationen oder haben sie gerade
einfach ins blaue speck mit josi daniel
bahr der finanzminister von baden
württemberg hört der bundesregierung
geplante aber in der grünen partei der
führende finanzpolitiker sagt offen dass
das ungünstig ist wie das gelaufen ist
und dass man darüber mit der fdp hatte
reden müssen etwas anderes geplant
wen wollen sie denn noch haben sie denn
andere quellen auch aus der
bundesregierung oder haben sie jetzt
gerade noch über einen kompromiss
zwischen fdp und grünen gibt kein
kontrolleur ist es wahr dass der bürger
was ganz anderes interessiert nein ich
wollte nur darauf hinweisen dass
alexander hier einfach spekuliert und
wollte nach seiner quelle fragen und er
hat keiner aus der bundesregierung also
mein er hat wir haben ja von frau grimm
schon gehört dass es nicht besonders
motivierend ist und von den bürgern auch
nicht besonders verstanden wird wir
hören sie jetzt ganz schnell noch mal
grillen nach perpignan entschuldigung
ja es lohnt sich vielleicht einfach noch
mal auf die aktuelle situation
hinzuweisen und die frage wie hoch
steigen die gaspreise dann in wir reden
jetzt die ganze zeit über die umlage von
2 verwendet sogar hinweis ich heute
jetzt wieder freunde neue verträge
sie heben sich durch eine neue verträge
sind
ungefähr dabei sechs cent aber die
aktuelle verträge sind teilweise noch
bei 6 cent aber die neuen verträge sind
teilweise schon bei 30 cent das heißt
die gaskunden werden wenn die anhebung
der kosten möglich ist wir haben ja eben
schon gehört das ist nicht immer möglich
es wird auch unrechtmäßig aktuell der
preis angehoben aber die gaskunden auf
die werden noch signifikante
kostensteigerungen zu kommen das sind
die direkt kunden die den jetzt schon
ausgesetzt sind aber im bereich der
mieter werden die abschläge ja immer
berechnet aufgrund des vorjahres
verbraucher das heißt die ganzen mieter
zahlen aktuell noch viel zu geringe
abschläge und werden bei der abrechnung
im sommer 23 sehr sehr hohe
nachzahlungen erleiden und da ist es
natürlich so ist uns eigentlich jetzt
gedanken machen müssen will kann man
diese massive von einer auch eine
gleiche der leist kunden ab fangen sie
mit ihr ist noch ein problem von ganz
anderem ausmaß als bei der noch viel
größere das ist eine viel höhere
kostensteigerungen und das wäre meine
überleitung gewesen ich wollte nicht
unhöflich sein und sie unbedingt hören
ob sie noch etwas zu dieser umlage sagen
wollen stichwort mehrbelastung die
diskussion um diese umlage kann
verstellen dass die menschen vor einem
noch viel größeren problem stehen hier
ist es
gaspreise schießen in die höhe vor einem
jahr musste ein singlehaushalt 430 euro
bezahlen ab oktober sind es 1073 bei
einem zweipersonenhaushalt
verdreifacht sich die gasrechnung im
selben zeitraum auf
2463 euro jährlich
dreimal so viel zahlt ab oktober auch
eine vierköpfige familie
3633 euro
sowie sind frau bald nochmal bei der
feststellung dass das natürlich ein
wahnsinn ist er auf die menschen dazu
kommt wann beginnt man dagegen vor zu
bauen und können sie den bürgern raten
etwas zu tun was wir hier auch schon
diskutiert haben den menschen zu sagen
sie sollen freiwillig ihre abschläge
beispielsweise erhöhen wenn sie denn
könnten
das konnte man auf den bürgertreff an es
kommt vor allem auch auf dem versorger
darauf an oder auch auf dem vermieter in
dem ich das geld in die hand drücken
habe ich auch so viel vertrauen
dass ich das wieder sehr wenn ja auch
weniger verbraucht habe bzw dass da
nicht trotzdem insolvent geht dann also
wie gesagt es gibt freie versorger immer
noch am markt
da muss man sehr vorsichtig sein was man
da vorher schon mal vor schießt
ja wer sich das leisten kann und der
kann ruhig seine nebenkostenabrechnung
also den anteil nebenkosten ruhig
erhöhen denn es ist ja nicht so dass nur
die verbraucher sozusagen der bredouille
sind es geht ja auch um die vermieter
und es gibt tatsächlich auch um die
stadtwerke die müssen natürlich auch
erst mal in vorleistung gehen und das
kann niemand wollen dass irgendeiner von
den konkurs geht
deswegen wer sich das leisten kann und
auch so gestrickt ist ich bin zum
beispiel nicht der kann auch sagen okay
höhe freiwillig meine abschläge ja wenn
ich selbst dass ich am ende dann nicht
mehr allzu hohen nachforderungen habt
nach forderung kommt so und so
wahrscheinlich wie sie sind weil bei der
frage warum der staat ich suche weiter
nach alternativen oder nach einem
programm für die zukunft um die menschen
durch diese krise zu bringen warum der
staat eigentlich nicht dauerhaft die
steuern auf die energie senkt es gibt
ein mindeststeuersatz denen die eu
festlegt die deutsche regierung hat sich
aus gründen entschieden das nicht zu tun
könnte auch das ein modell sein zu sagen
in dieser exorbitanten krise die
wenigstens zwei jahre dauern wird die
energie ja nur ein teil ist helfen wir
den menschen und senken dauerhaft die
energiesteuern dass das problem ist ja
also zum einen die niederlage ist
abgehakt das war schon wichtig und jetzt
ist die mehrwertsteuer auf gas gesenkt
worden das problem bei solchen maßnahmen
ist immer das ist die berühmte gießkanne
und die ist natürlich sehr schnell und
auch für alle gleichermaßen da aber wir
haben eine sehr unterschiedliche
betroffenheit
das sieht man ich glaube sie haben
angedeutet dass menschen mit dem
niedrigen einkommen aber auch mit mit
reinkommt sich die allergrößten sorgen
aber es gibt eben auch viele für die es
ist ein riesen ärgernis aber deswegen
müssen sie kleine schlaflose nacht haben
und was wir jetzt wirklich in erster
linie machen müssen uns ist ob
diejenigen zu konzentrieren die es
dringend nötig haben da herrscht oft
angst und ich glaube es gibt jetzt auch
einfach die staatliche verpflichtung
menschen denn dieser oft in dieser
situation sicherheit zu geben und das
hat für mich voran wer sind diese
menschen die es wirklich brauchen
das fragen wir uns und sie und einer von
denen könnte sabrina scholz aus
ludwigshafen sein
sabrina scholz ist seit kurzem
krankenpflegerin sie hat 2500 euro im
monat zur verfügung aber mit drei
kindern und einer miete von 830 euro
warm reicht es für die alleinerziehende
hinten und vorne nicht ihr 16 jähriger
sohn braucht geld für essen schule sport
jetzt fürchtet sie die heizkosten im
herbst und winter ich habe jetzt eine
kleine urlaubskasse zugelegt und das
geld was da drin das war eigentlich für
den urlaub gedacht und da ist jetzt
etwas übertreiben und euro drin
aber wahrscheinlich wird das für die
heizkosten drauf gehen kann ich mir gut
vorstellen auch beim einkaufen bloß
nichts überflüssiges 100 euro pro woche
veranschlagt sabrina scholz für sich und
die kinder ihrem jüngsten emiliano muss
sie häufig etwas ausschlagen sehe ich
einfach dass er nicht versuchen die
teuren regale greift sondern einfach
die angebote
einfach auf die angebote schauen der
kanzler herbei will jetzt in ruhe ein
konzept erarbeiten wird er diese ruhe
haben oder könnte er auf die art und
weise auch ihre wiederwahl gefährden am
ersten oktober wenn das nicht möglich
schnell geht ob ich wiedergewählt werde
oder nicht das ist vergleichsweise
unerheblich im vergleich zu dem problem
vor dem wir stehen wir haben ja im
moment nieder sagt in niedersachsen
wahlkampf mit vielen menschen kontakt
und es ist wirklich so dass da eine mit
den händen zu greifende unsicherheit ist
und die wollen vor allen dingen eins
diese menschen klarheit und deswegen bei
allem respekt für ruhe und
nachdenklichkeit jetzt muss auch
tatsächlich sehr schnell gehandelt
werden von mir aus am besten morgen denn
diese frage wie machen wir das denn
beispielsweise bei diesem beispiel wie
kann man einer solchen frau die sich
wirklich große sorgen machen muss die
sind ja nicht ausgedacht das dürfen wir
nicht auf die lange bank schieben das
muss schnell gehen und von mir aus
morgen gerne auch am wochenende aber
schnell gut also jetzt sind wir genau
bei dem problem wie der linke seite des
tisches alexander schnell und zielsicher
das sind eigentlich zwei orte die sich
ausschließen weil wenn ich etwas schnell
mache dann kann ich nicht danach schauen
dass es eine zielsichere unterstützung
ist
das glaube ich nicht das sind
komplizierte dinge aber die regierung
hat ja genug leute oder kann auch nach
verstand zu greifen es gibt dort einfach
da kommen partner zusammen aus sehr
unterschiedlichen weltanschaulichen
richtung und müssen kompromisse finden
die dann schwierig sind und olaf scholz
hatte am anfang versprochen er
konzentriert sich mit seiner regierung
aus machbare also nicht den streit
sondern gemeinsame lösung die nach
vorher und jetzt haben wir schon den
ganzen abend darüber gesprochen wo der
streit ist deshalb ist ja erstaunlich
dass ein spd-ministerpräsident kaum
verhohlen die bundesregierung und damit
den kanzler auffordert jetzt schnell für
klarheit zu sorgen ich würde auch sagen
das muss jetzt wirklich passieren und
nicht nur aus wieder gründen der ball
der den gründen der einer wiederwahl
herr lindner
direktzahlungen an die bürger könnten
hält sie sind einigermaßen unkompliziert
und könnten auch schnell gehen aber das
ist auch etwas wo sie sagen das kommt
jetzt auf gar keinen fall nochmal
infrage um einen zeitraum iks zu
überprüfen überbrücken entschuldigung
einen zeitraum zu überbrücken bis man
eben noch zu anderen reformen können
also teile
direktzahlung ich schließe nichts aus
sind als regierung dabei jetzt gerade
ein konzept zu machen kein alexander hat
völlig recht es sind drei partner die
sehr unterschiedlich sind zwei parteien
links der mitte und eine partei der
mitte aber wir haben keinen streit auch
jetzt die zuletzt getroffenen
entscheidungen auf wenn wir von
unterschiedlichen richtungen kamen und
wir gemeinsam vertreten habe ich hier
heute auch getan und so schauen wir
jetzt nach vorne
wir haben gerade das beispiel der
krankenpflegerin gesehen mit ihren drei
kindern
wir arbeiten an einer wohngeldreform
also menschen mit einem kleinen
einkommen rentnerinnen und rentner
bekommen dann einen zuschuss zur miete
aber dann künftig auch zu den heizkosten
das betrifft übrigens auch die
rentnerinnen und den rentner die im
eigenheim sind es nicht nur bezogen auf
mieter sondern auch kann ja sein was das
ganze leben nicht krumm gemacht hast
dann die eigentumswohnung hast das haus
und dann hast du denn noch angst wegen
der kleinen rente von der gasrechnung
die können davon auch profitieren das
zweite sind die menschen in
grundsicherung also man sagt wir wollen
das ersetzen durch das schaffen sie noch
bis oktober handy des ersten ersten
nächsten jahres wird das sein
und diese menschen dann übernehmen wir
die heizkosten dass unsere gesellschaft
sehr solidarisch muss man auch mal sagen
die menschen auch mit kleinem einkommen
die steuern zahlen übernehmen die
kompletten heizkosten für die menschen
in der grundsicherung allein das in zehn
milliarden euro an solidarität in dieser
gesellschaft und nicht nennen dritten
punkt darüber haben wir heute noch nicht
gesprochen aber das ist einer der auch
viele menschen besorgt das sind die
steigenden stromkosten das hängt mit dem
gas zusammen die stromrechnungen
explodieren und mich beschäftigt das
geradezu tag und nacht weil wir da eine
ganz ungerechte situation haben
aufgrund des höheren
gaspreises steigt der strompreis und
auch diejenigen die strom produzieren
aus sonne und wind die bekommen jetzt
den strompreis bezahlt als hätten sie
das teure gas eingekauft hört sich ein
bisschen kompliziert an ist auch
kompliziert ist im ergebnis aber eine
gelddruckmaschine für die die aus kohle
aus solar und aus wind strom machen dann
stehen unglaubliche gewinne am
strommarkt zu lasten der
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher und
hier müssen wir uns etwas einfallen
lassen wie wir das unternehmen das
letzte kraftwerk zählt die unter das
teuer ist der
gewünschte nein das ist keine
klaren nein das ist keine keine über
gewinn steuer aber es ein problem dass
unser strommarkt wie sie zurecht sagen
frau illner daran orientiert was ist das
letzte kraftwerk das zugeschaltet wird
das letzte kraftwerk ist ein teures gas
kraftwerk und das beständige den preis
für alle anderen auch für das günstige
solarkraftwerk und gestatten sie im
vierten letzten punkt ich habe ja gerade
beschrieben wir kümmern uns um die
besonders betroffen sind wir dürfen aber
nicht die leute vergessen ich sage mal
die 40.000 euro verdienst dass mittlere
einkommen in deutschland ja auf jeden
fall dazu verschwinde ich nur sagen
dürfen wir nicht vergessen er ihn können
wir nicht breitflächige entlastungen in
aussicht stellen aber zumindest dürfen
diese menschen nicht zusätzlich belasten
gut und jetzt nehmen sie mir nicht übel
dass ich einmal auf ihren eingangssatz
nochmal rekurrieren sie sagen die ampel
ist da gemeinsam unterwegs und man
kämpft in die richtige richtung und es
gibt jetzt ein drittes gemeinsames
entlastungspaket sie haben in der
zwischenzeit in bezug auf das nur ein
euro ticket von einer gratis mentalität
gesprochen sie haben gesagt das ist
linke streaming sei wenn man jetzt über
eine über gewinn steuer nach der heute
wird das nehme man über die abschaffung
der pauschalbesteuerung bei
geschäftswagen nachdenkt das war
bestimmt die looks so richtig dann auch
noch richtig binden das
dienstwagenprivileg viele man hat nicht
wirklich den eindruck dass da so viel
frieden herrscht parallel dazu bekommt
man als bürger waschlappen und du
stipendium der grünen seite also ist da
so viel einigkeit dass sie glauben sie
bekommen noch mal für den oktober eine
reisezeit in deutschland ein
entlastungspaket hin
wir werden noch vor oktober klarheit
haben über das entlastungspaket für den
für den winter
das ist zwingend die haushaltsberatungen
des deutschen bundestages beginnen im
september
das heißt die maßnahmen die in das
haushaltsgesetz eingearbeitet werden
sollen müssen dann ja auch irgendwann
bekannt sein und ich will ihnen ganz
klar sagen wir brauchen gezielte
entlastungsmaßnahmen
aber die lehre aus dem neuen euro ticket
ist nicht nahezu kostenfreier nahverkehr
in deutschland sondern die lehrer aus
dem neuen euro der übrigens auch nicht
ökologisch mit knappen kapazitäten so
umzugehen dass wurde 14 milliarden euro
kosten geld das wir für investitionen in
die schiene oder für bildung brauchen
aber die lehrer aus dem neuen euro
ticket ist eine andere der
tarifdschungel muss gelichtet werden das
muss einfacher werden unbürokratisch am
liebsten digital zu buchen und wenn es
dann eben dann auch noch günstiger wird
als bisher weil die länder auch in die
mitverantwortung gehen dann bin ich da
sofort dabei aber kostenfreie pnv weder
ökologisch nicht nachhaltig finanziert
und nichts zu machen wir sind eher weil
wir heute bei den gegenvorschlägen sie
sagen mit einer über gewinn steuer
könnten sie leben und könnten darüber
auch nach denken sie müssten mit für
mich ist das entscheidende dass der
staat jetzt handelt und dokumentiert er
steht an der seite der bürgerinnen und
bürger die es wirklich dringend nötig
wer sind die wo fangen die anklage ist
der glaube wir haben wir haben die erste
gruppe bis 900 euro die sind
typischerweise abhängig von staatlichen
sozialleistungen damit auf der sicheren
seite aber von 900 euro netto im monat
bis 2600 euro netto monate sind über ein
drittel aller haushalte über ein drittel
aller haushalte und wenn man dahinter
schaut wird neben glaube ich ein ganz
gutes beispiel dann stellt man fest 2600
das klingt auf den ersten blick klingt
schön ist ganz viel weg und das sind
genau diese menschen auch direkt aus der
mitte der gesellschaft sind in vielen
fällen sind dass menschen die arbeiten
beide in einer familie und nun kommt so
kommen diese zahlen zustande und die
müssen sich jetzt größte sorgen mann und
deswegen sollte man sich jetzt auch
nichts vormachen was die reichweite
einer wirksam wohngeldreform animusx das
wären millionen von menschen die davon
betroffen wären und ich hoffe dass es
allen beteiligten klar denn so weit
reicht das und man muss noch eins wissen
wir sind nicht am startpunkt der krise
oder am ende der krise wir sind frau
grimm sagte dass am anfang wir sind am
anfang der krise das heißt wir müssen
jetzt die weichen so stellen dass die
menschen ohne existenzielle not in die
zukunft blicken können das ist eine
wirklich extrem schwierige aufgabe und
deswegen würde ich mir auch wünschen
diese ganzen zweitrangigen debatten gibt
man jetzt eine weile beiseite zu
schieben und sich auf das zu
konzentrieren worum es wirklich geht und
was geht den leuten unter druck aber es
geht um richtig viel geld das der staat
da auch braucht weil wir wollen nicht
vergessen dass parallel ja noch etwas
darüber liegendes zu lösen ist nämlich
das klimaproblem das heißt wir geben
jetzt wahnsinnig viel geld und
anstrengung in fossile energien und
haben eigentlich parallel noch den
planeten zu retten aber diese zwei jahre
wird es sehr sehr viel geld brauchen wir
sind wieder bei diesem thema muss an der
schuldenbremse gedreht werden weil wir
einen ja weil man das nicht einfach aus
der portokasse macht seinen ersten
punkte vorher lindner den sagt ich
glaube das ist eine gesamtstaatliche
aufgabe da müssen alle mithelfen also ob
bund und länder aber
würde haben sich nachher gleich ein
bisschen redezeit gespannt zweitens
wir haben zwei möglichkeiten entweder
wir erhöhen die steuereinnahmen da sind
die möglichkeiten sehr begrenzt weil wir
jetzt auch aufpassen müssen dass wir
nicht die kaufkraft noch reduzieren das
ist auch noch ein sonderthema wie geht
es mit der konjunktur weiter oder aber
wir besorgen uns auf dem kapitalmarkt
auch notwendige möglichkeit theoretisch
gibt es noch die dritte aus möglichkeit
dass der staat die irgendwo spart wenn
das mal theoretisch in den raum gestellt
das afrikanisch dass man da noch
juristisch riesige mengen mobilisiert
das ist nicht zu erwarten ehrlich gesagt
so und da ich wie gesagt beim thema
steuererhöhungen über gewinn steuer
beispielsweise kann man mit mir gut
drüber reden aber das wird jetzt am ende
auch nicht die sache entscheiden können
eher vorsichtig wäre glaube ich
persönlich es ist jetzt die notlage die
schuldenbremse gibt ja möglichkeiten
also ich argumentiere auf dem boden der
schuldenbremse aber ich glaube eine
notlage die tritt nicht erst dann ein
wenn das kind schon in den brunnen
gefallen ist wir sind jetzt mal im
feuerwehr deutsch zu sprechen in der
armee noch die chance vor die lage zu
kommen wir sollten nicht so lange warten
bis tatsächlich aus ich sag mal
schutzschirm rettungsschirme werden um
mal so ein bild zu verwenden sondern
jetzt muss der staat vor die lage kommen
er muss jetzt handeln die weichen
richtig stellen und damit auch
sicherheit wir machen noch einmal
deutlich in welcher politischen
auseinandersetzung sich die ampel gerade
befindet nein mach ich nicht ich frage
entschuldigung er ist nochmal frau bald
danach was sie denken frau ballot wie
viele menschen in diesem land werden am
ende unterstützung brauchen wir sagen
oder hören von der politik immer
zielgenau es muss denen geholfen werden
die es brauchen werden die nicht ganz
ganz viele sein und zwar so viele wie
wir noch nie hatten eben weil es diese
preissteigerungen gibt die wir sehen und
die wir auch noch gar nicht bis zu ende
abschätzen können weil wenn die gase die
richtige gas mangel lage tatsächlich
eintritt dann geht das richtig steil ab
und dann ist die mitte der gesellschaft
locker erreicht die das nicht mehr
zahlen kann also davon können wir
ausgehen
dass werden richtig viel also ja ausbau
da wo also diese wohngeldreform die ist
extrem wichtig in die man dann auch die
heizkosten integrieren würde genau dann
werden die miet- und die heizkosten
ja-anteil ich zumindest anteilig oder
vollständig übernehmen
damit ist immer noch nicht der anstieg
der strompreise oder der anstieg von
irgendwelchen anderen preisen gelöst ne
also deswegen
griffin der reformierung der hartz 4
sätze und sowas zum anfang nächsten
jahres ist ja schön und gut das hilft
den leuten aber nicht über den winter
weil die abschläge für die strompreise
die sind jetzt einfach dinge werden wir
sind frau grimm hebt den finger und
sofort ist sie dann
jetzt hören wir sie gerade nicht
ausgerechnet
wir kriegen ihren ton wir können ihren
ton gerade nicht hören frau grimm
entschuldigung dann ist christian
lindner dran und sie sehen uns dass nach
die technik probiert nochmal perpignan
mit berlin zu verbinden herlinde eine
wirklich wichtige frage wir reden über
eine nicht zu kalkulierende zahl von
menschen die gegebenenfalls in diesem
land staatliche unterstützung brauchen
wo setzt der bundesfinanzminister diese
grenze wer wird sich trauen zu
formulieren wer hilfe bekommt und wer
nicht wir haben drei dinge zu tun
erstens das was sie gerade geschildert
haben die wirklich bedürftigen menschen
dürfen und werden nicht alleine gelassen
auch nicht in diesem winter auch nicht
im nächsten jahr das ist unsere
gemeinsame verantwortung da sind per
solidarisch und das betrifft auch die
mitte der gesellschaft
also die menschen die arbeiten wir haben
eben eine alleinerziehende mutter
gesehen die ist fleißig die arbeitet
vollzeit hatte dennoch größte sorgen und
da wird es eine unterstützung geben ist
die erste aufgabe die zweite aufgabe ist
wir müssen alles in unserer macht
stehende tun und die preisentwicklung
unter kontrolle zu bekommen beim gas
bedeutet dass mit einer knappen
ressourcen sparsam umgehen
flüssiggasterminals installieren und
schnell auch lieferungen von woanders
bekommen und beim strom habe ich ja
schon gesagt so wie gegenwärtig der
preis beim strom gebildet wird entstehen
gewinne ohne dass dahinter eine
investition oder ein unternehmerisches
risiko steht und da müssen wir rein
damit nicht die mangel lage beim gas
dazu führt dass er beim strom für jeden
haushalt exorbitanten preissteigerungen
haben übrigens in europa sind sich
darüber einig dass so wie der strommarkt
gegenwärtig in dieser krise organisiert
ist es nicht weitergehen kann sondern
dann müssen wir eine lösung finden
übergangsweise und der dritte punkt nun
ist wir müssen die wurzel der inflation
bekämpfen
und ein beitrag den der staat leisten
kann ist dass er nicht auf dauer immer
alles mit neuen schulden finanziert
würden wir die inflationsentwicklung
anheizen die bundesbank der unabhängig
ist hat gerade gestern nochmal
öffentlich gesagt in ihrem sogenannten
monatsbericht dass sie dazu rät im
nächsten jahr die schuldenbremse
einzuhalten und da sind sie jetzt beim
finanzminister der muss das
zusammenbringt er einerseits die
massiven hilfen für die menschen die
besonders betroffen sind die
investitionen das wir unabhängiger
werden und dass wir die preise unter
kontrolle bekommen und dann das dritte
dass wir auch zur schuldenbremse
zurückkehren und das ist unser ehrgeiz
als koalition insgesamt das zu leisten
dass der bundeskanzler ja sehr klar ich
helfe macht der chef der bundesbank hat
aber auch gesagt mit dem auslaufen des
neuen euro ticket und das bankgeheimnis
krankenbett ich habe heute einen wechsel
staaten verbucht die buchstaben
haben wir wenigstens ein prozent
inflation mehr also mit dem auslaufen
von bestimmten maßnahmen erhöht man
natürlich auch zunächst mal die
inflation und die große wird aber wieder
sinken durch den reduzierten
mehrwertsteuersatz auf gas nur für die
bürgerinnen und bürger ist marina
debatte statistik das ist zunächst mal
für die menschen entscheidend ist der
kühlschrank am ende des monats voll und
wie gehe ich um mit der abschlag zum und
hier ist meine frage zur schuldenbremse
wir nehmen den gedanken von 1 weil auf
weil wir ihn nicht vergessen wollen
schuldenbremse heißt ja nichts schwarze
null schuldenbremse heißt ja nicht dass
keine zusätzlichen schulden aufnehmen im
nächsten jahr sondern es gibt eine
ausnahme für die schuldenbremse die
heißt entweder eine naturkatastrophe
gegen die sich ein land nicht wehren
kann oder eine außergewöhnliche
wirtschaftliche notlage die nicht
staatlich selbst verschuldet aber den
staat an den grenzen die grenzen seiner
handlungsfähigkeit bringt oder so
ähnlich heißt das sie dürfen nächstes
jahr schulden machen und halten trotzdem
die schuldenbremse ein wir machen
nächstes jahr schulden die
schuldenbremse erlaubt nach der
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung einer
kreditaufnahme man verwechselt das oft
mit der so genannten schwarzen null also
einem haushalt ohne neue schulden das
ist die schuldenbremse nicht ich plane
gegenwärtig mit etwa 17 milliarden euro
neuen schulden im nächsten jahr ja und
dutzenden milliarden euro die wir aus
einer rücklage einsetzen man kann nicht
davon sprechen wir hätten im nächsten
jahr ein sparhaushalt so wir machen uns
auf den weg in richtung wieder
nachhaltig solide finanzen das ist auch
klar erstens bachler ist also sparen
nächstes jahr nicht geben viel geld aus
weil wir solche möglichkeiten haben sagt
dafür vorgesehen jetzt zu der frage kann
man eine ausnahme von der schuldenbremse
machen darf man ist nach meiner
einschätzung nach meiner rechtlichen
einschätzung sind uns da mehr oder
weniger die hände gebunden denn die
ausnahme von der schuldenbremse setzt
voraus dass ist ein nicht vorhersehbaren
schock von außen gibt den gab es mit dem
ukraine krieg deshalb habe ich als
finanzminister das zweite
entlastungspaket mit einer neuen
aussagen nächstes jahr bitte lassen sie
mich einmal den satz weil sie sehr oft
diskutierte zu ende sein das zweite
entlastungspaket mit einer ausnahme von
der schuldenbremse finanziert
unmittelbar nach dem ukraine krieg
überraschenden vorhersehbar leider leben
wir jetzt seit monaten in der traurigen
realität
wir reden jetzt über gas embargo wir
reden über wirtschaftskrise und da sagt
eigentlich die verfassung solche
probleme solche strukturellen
herausforderungen müssen im rahmen der
schuldenbremse gelöst werden durch
höhere einnahmen niedrigere ausgaben
prioritäten setzt okay aber inhalt ist
gleich meine nächste frage festhalten ob
wir nicht einfach für menschen die es
sich leisten könnten die abgaben erhöhen
dürften und hier ist der blick in das
politische geschehen gerne
für die drei von der tankstelle geht es
ans eingemachte das dritte
entlastungspaket
müssen es innerhalb der grenzen der
schuldenbremse und ohne steuererhöhungen
finanzieren spricht's und steigt in den
dienstwagen 3 milliarden entgehen dem
fiskus durch deren private nutzung sagen
die grünen kein thema für lindner wie
überhaupt fast alles rot grüne
dann machen wir auch jetzt ein
übergewicht steuer damit finanzieren wir
entlastungen wir brauchen eine nachfolge
für das 9 euro ticket
[Musik]
lindner will lieber inflationsausgleich
durch abschaffung der kalten progression
erwünschter nebeneffekt das hilft auch
gutverdienern gasrechnung die kosten
sind ja komme auf alle zu dann sollten
nicht diejenigen die 60 80
hunderttausend euro verdienen mehr
bekommen als diejenigen die vielleicht
16 18 oder nur 12.000 euro verdient
darum muss es jetzt gehen kleine und
mittlere einkommen zu entlasten
da habe ich andere vorstellungen im
detail lässt der finanzminister
das sollten sie noch mal gesehen haben
liebe zuschauer weil er linda hat schon
gesagt bombenstimmung super stimmung in
der ampel in bezug auf dieses dritte
entlastungspaket kommt müssen sie gleich
kommt das geld bei den richtigen an herr
alexander da das dritte entlastungspaket
noch nicht beschlossen das gar nicht die
frage ob es die richtigen ankommt bei
aller liebe inhalt der aktion war der
letzte gedanke entschuldigung ich hätte
es präzise sagen müssen alle diese
äußerungen bezogen sich auf die kalte
progression und den streit innerhalb der
ampel um diese zehn milliarden ist nicht
richtig glücklich dass herr lindner
heute so kritisch mit mir aber das gibt
mir die freiheit ihn jetzt zu loben weil
diese ab also diese korrektur der kalten
progression nach jeder überhaupt nichts
neoliberales teufelszeug oder so das ist
klassische eigentlich
sozialdemokratische politik das hat wohl
auf scholz' immer gemacht das ist sehe
ich auch so werden weil es einfach die
wahrheit ist und er hat ja sogar noch
eigentlich die dass das schöne drin dass
ein paar mehr leute in die reichensteuer
rutschen ja und wenn wir das jetzt nicht
oder wenn das nicht gemacht würde
stellen sie sich doch mal vor so ein
normaler sagen wenn man ein facharbeiter
der verein ig metall ist der tarif
kriegt der hat die hohe inflation einer
hacke der hat die gaspreise einer hacke
dann holt ihn seine gewerkschaften guten
und deren abschluss und dann sagt er
stark das ziehe ich jetzt aber ein ja
also ich meine dass das ist doch schön
dass wir das aufgeklärt haben es ist
eigentlich kein geschenk sondern es ist
das vermeiden eines zusätzlichen dazu
ist es ist eine frage der gerechtigkeit
und das kann man ganz einfach ist und
noch mal lena ich glaube wir haben jetzt
den ganzen film über mich grad und ja
aber man hat es glaube ich verstanden
ich glaube der bürger hat auch mit der
erklärung von ihnen und von herrn
alexander verstanden dass das nichts ist
was irgendjemandem besonders befördert
sondern nur nachteile aus man schon noch
mal sagen war robert habeck eben von 80
hunderttausend euro gesprochen hat der
effekt ist bei 62.000 euro begrenzt und
worum geht's dieses jahr sind 40.000
euro 40.000 euro wert nächstes jahr
werden 40.000 euro 37.000 euro sein und
ich muss leider sagen dass teile von spd
und die grünen sagen wenn nächstes jahr
40.000 euro 37 euro wert sind wollen wir
trotzdem steuern erheben als 40.000 euro
dass die sogenannte kalte progression
der zahlen menschen ihre gasrechnung
ihre stromrechnung und sollen trotzdem
noch mehr steuern zahlen auf weniger
kaufkraft und das finde ich nicht
gerechnet herr einheit schon gesagt dass
er sich gedanklich anschließt wir
machten den fehler finde ich nicht an
der stelle mit den plänen von linda da
habe ich keinen puls mehr wir machen ihn
an einer anderen stelle wir haben zb das
ist nachgewiesen im moment das den
umstand dass gerade menschen mit
besonders niedrigem einkommen
unterdurchschnittlich nur von den
entlastungs maße profitieren später
beispiel wirklich viel böses blut
gesorgt hat ist bei den rentnerinnen und
rentnern die anders als bundesminister
oder ministerpräsidenten dieser
einmalzahlung nicht bekommen haben und
das ist nicht verstehen auch nicht
verstehen können weil das kann man nicht
ernst gut begründen und an der stelle
muss man etwas gut machen und für die
zukunft daraus lernen nämlich wirklich
die priorität bei den kleinen einkommen
haben und das spricht überhaupt nichts
dagegen dass man gleichzeitig dafür
sorgt dass nicht unverhofft in einer
solchen situation menschen sich als
spitzenverdiener wiederfinden die sich
nun wirklich nicht so fühlen frau grimm
ist uns aus perpignan jetzt nicht nur
zugeschaltet sondern wir hören sie hier
in berlin sogar wieder vor gram einen
letzten kurzen gedanken von ihnen
nochmal zu diesem
also zu der fairness und der
gerechtigkeit wie groß ist ihre sorge
dass es nicht gelingen wird diese
gesellschaftliche solidarität zu
erreichen
ja ich glaube die herausforderung liegt
ihr oder das problem liegt hier in dem
timing auch ich glaube wir brauchen und
das wollte ich eben sagen als ich dann
nicht zu hören war wir brauchen ganz
dringend fokussierte entlastungen für
gas gründen denn es wurde ja vorher
schon gesagt man könnte sich entscheiden
seinen abschlag zu ändern aber man kann
sich gar nicht entscheiden sein abschlag
zu erhöhen wenn man gar nicht weiß ob
man sich das überhaupt leisten kann und
das betrifft wirklich viele das sind
massive kostensteigerungen die auf die
leute zu kommen und ich glaube das muss
jetzt parallel mindestens parallel von
geklärt werden und man muss sich daneben
natürlich überlegen wie man für die
sonstigen kostensteigerung entlastet ich
glaube beim strompreis ist die lage noch
etwas anders ich glaube auch das sind
sehr herausfordernde entwicklung wieder
auf uns zukommen aber da kann man auch
beim angebot natürlich was machen da
müssen wir ganz ganz dringend dafür
sorgen dass das angebot
da ist im sinne von kohlekraftwerke
aktivieren im sinne von auch die
atomkraftwerke noch einmal verlängern
damit eben tatsächlich der marktpreis
nicht so stark in die höhe schießt es
sind knapp heizkreise und die sind auch
dadurch getrieben dass aktuell das
stromangebot in europa einfach nicht da
ist wenn wir den preis deckeln ohne
gleichzeitig auch für eine erhöhung des
angebotes zu sorgen dann haben wir das
nächste problem eigentlich so stiglitz
der nobelpreisträger sagt heute die
deutschen müssen unbedingt pragmatisch
sein sowohl in bezug auf das fracking
als auch in bezug auf die atomenergie
als auch in bezug auf kohle und aufwind
und wir sollen einfach alles machen und
mit unserer ideologie aufhören nur um
ihn auch noch mal zu zitieren wichtig
ist was frau ballot zu den menschen
trägt und von ihnen hört wie sehr
fordern auch bei ihnen schon bürger dass
wir eigentlich über den sinn dieser
sanktionen nachdenken müssen wie groß
ist ihre sorge dass
die solidarität also ich bin ja auch
aktionstagen und messen und auch meine
kollegen erzählen mir dass wir werden
jetzt tatsächlich auch persönlich
angegriffen also wir müssen jetzt gerade
stehen für die
politik der bundesregierung und der
landesregierung und auch wir haben jetzt
vermehrt irgendwelche leute die genau
eröffnet nord stream 2 oder schließt
jetzt frieden mit putin oder solchen
geschichten kommen und wenn du dann doch
mal fragt warum oder wenn sie etwas
erklären willst dass es ja auch seinen
grund hat das wir so abhängig sind von
diesem russischen gas und dass das ja
eigentlich der grund krebs ist in der
jetzigen situation
dann hören die auch gar nicht zu na also
die die stimm und also das ist das eine
und das andere ist eben wirklich dass
die leute verzweifelt sind einfach mal
die verstehen die welt überhaupt nicht
mehr das leben lang gespart und jetzt
stehen sie da vor die hütte zu verlieren
ja und da
beziehungsweise sie haben auch angst
weise nicht nur wissen wo die reise
hingehen sollen sie wissen auch gar
nicht bleibt das jetzt wirklich warm im
winter wird ist das reicht das gas jetzt
tatsächlich und da muss ich jetzt mal
sagen was auf jeden fall fehlt von der
bundesregierung das ist mal zu sagen in
diesem winter und wahrscheinlich auch im
nächsten winter gibt es keine energie
sparen wird es auch keine
wohnungskündigung geben damit ihr die
zeit habt euch um hilfe zu kümmern und
dann dass man kriegt nicht innerhalb von
zwei tagen irgendwo in irgendeiner
beratungseinrichtungen termin unseren
antrag auf wohngeld oder was ist auch
nicht innerhalb von zwei tagen gestellt
das kann schon mal monate dauern also
bei uns in thüringen dauert sehr freuen